well 30 seconds for prague he's gonna  keep fighting right it's not like he's  gonna give up right now i think until  that black pawn continues to break  through or until something else drops  yeah you're only one pawn down for now  so keep fighting the computer does say  plus five nearly yeah so that means that  it's almost hopeless but  in human terms  nine seconds for brag it's not much time  it's always very uh  nerve-wracking yeah the players let the  seconds tick down  okay so the rook moves across you know  potentially setting up a trap as the two  rooks eye each other out there's  unfortunately i think this might be the  killer black's rook is just removing the  blockade of his seaporn white's rook now  on the c2 square stuck if you trade off  rooks black is just going to create beth  the b pawn again and going to queen that  pawn again  and there we go we have a result ding  takes it wow it's over again with the  black pieces ding wins this game